les oeuvres caritatives dont s'occupait
la princesse diana boîte afflué depuis
quelques jours maintenant des dons
petits et grands qui représente déjà
plusieurs millions de livres etienne et
n'a à londres dans le hall d'un hôpital
pour enfants des dessins 17 à leur
manière la tristesse d'une disparition
si l'hommage qui lui est rendu a surpris
par son ampleur il faut sans doute
trouver une explication dans ses causes
que la princesse de galles avait su
défend enfants malades lutte contre le
sida toutes ces associations dont elle
était la marraine et qui aujourd'hui se
sent orpheline bénéficieront largement
de l'immense élan de solidarité provoqué
par sa disparition ce qu'elles ont perdu
à jamais en revanche c'est la faculté
qu'elle avait d'attirer les yeux du
monde sur des combats qu'elle menait
malgré des inconvénients que présenter
pour elle le fait d'être une femme très
connu le point positif est évidemment
c'est que toutes les choses en
lesquelles elle croyait et bien après
sans parler simplement parce que c'était
tel 350 appels par heure le fond diana
mise en place au lendemain de sa mort a
déjà récolté plus d'un milliard de
francs et devrait très rapidement
devenir la première oeuvre de charité au
monde nous avons eu des dons très
touchant un enfant envoyé de francs de
son argent de poche deux petites pièces
de monnaie scotché sur une carte
ça n'arrête jamais
l'adaptation de candle in the wind
qu'elton john chanté samedi sera mise en
vente en fin de semaine et promet d'être
vite épuisé cet après midi kensington
palace reste est le site le plus visité
de la capitale britannique
mais l'atmosphère est à changer on vient
pour voir plutôt que pour pleurer
bientôt les fleurs ont disparu les
messages et les poèmes seront archivés
et comme si la vie devait bien reprendre
un jour le drapeau britannique qui
depuis samedi frotter en berne sur
buckingham palace comme une entorse au
protocole royal a été abaissée d'ousmane
dabo